حسنًا ، يبدو أن الرئيس بايدن يقترب شيئًا فشيئًا
الآن
من أحد أهداف سياسته
الخارجية المهمة ، وهو الانضمام مجددًا إلى
اتفاق اليابان النووي
الإيراني الذي انسحب الرئيس ترامب
من جانب واحد في عام 2018 من
الاجتماع الافتراضي الذي عقده الأعضاء الآخرون في
لجنة العلاقات الخارجية.
أنه سيكون هناك
اجتماع متابعة
وجهًا لوجه في فيينا في غضون أسبوع ،
سيكون للولايات المتحدة
ممثلين هناك في فيينا ،
فلن يجلسوا
حول الطاولة مع هؤلاء
الأعضاء الآخرين مع روسيا
مع الصين مع أوروبا  الاتحاد
مع المملكة المتحدة
مع إيران وفرنسا وألمانيا ، كل
هؤلاء الأعضاء الرئيسيين في
JCPOA ، لن تكون الولايات المتحدة حول الطاولة ، لكن
يبدو أن هذا
يتجه ببطء نحو هذا الموقف الذي قالت
الولايات المتحدة إنها
تريد الوصول إلى حيث  سوف
يدرس رفع العقوبات عن
إيران التي رفعتها إيران ذات مرة ، كانت قد
قالت سابقًا إن الولايات المتحدة لا يمكنها الانضمام مرة أخرى إلى لجنة
السياسة النقدية المشتركة حتى يتم رفع تلك العقوبات
، وقالت الولايات المتحدة إن إيران يجب أن تأتي
بالكامل  تواصل مع قادة jcpoa
الذين يبدو أنهما موقفان متبادلان
اتخذهما الاتحاد الأوروبي دورًا في محاولة التقريب
بين الجانبين ، لذا
اقترب أكثر من ذلك مع ما
قد تسميه محادثات
التقارب في فيينا في غضون أسبوع ولكن
النتيجة  من هذه الجلسة الافتراضية ،
يبدو الآن أنه يدفع بالموقف
أقرب الآن إلى احتمال عودة إيران
إلى الامتثال لـ
jcpoa ، لقد خرجوا عن الامتثال
بشكل كبير على اليورانيوم المنخفض
التخصيب وعدد من
القضايا الأخرى أيضًا.  إعادة مطالبة الولايات
المتحدة بإزالة العقوبات
لذلك ليس من الواضح بالضبط
كيف ستسير المحادثات
وتسلسل الأحداث هنا
ولكن مرة أخرى خطوة للأمام نيك روبرتسون سي إن
لندن